herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf heute
live stream der anlass ist ein trauriger
großbritannien trauert um prinz philip
prinz philip der ehemann der britischen
queen elizabeth der zweite ist am frühen
morgen verstorben teilte buckingham
palace mit der duke of edinburgh ist 99
jahre alt geworden im juni wäre er 100
geworden aber prinz philip sein
gesundheitlicher zustand war nicht der
beste vor wenigen wochen war er lange
zeit im krankenhaus hatte eine schwere
operation am herzen im märz wurde er
wieder entlassen kehrte zurück in den
buckingham palace wo er jetzt am frühen
morgen friedlich eingeschlafen ist die
bbc spielte die nationalhymne der
britische premierminister boris johnson
gilt eine ansprache live im fernsehen
und würdigte philipp als stärke und
stütze der queen und erklärte dass das
ganze land gemeinsam mit ihrer majestät
queen elizabeth der zweite um den
prinzen trauert wir wollen nach
großbritannien genauer nach london
schalten vor buckingham palace steht
meine kollegin unsere großbritannien
korrespondentin diana zimmermann diana
wie ist die stimmung wie ist die
situation hinter dir sind viele menschen
denn schon in london vor buckingham
palast zusammen gekommen ja man kann
hier sehen auf buckingham halles hängt
der unique auf halbmast man sieht dann
ist nicht besonders gut gerade und die
menschen stehen an gerade ein bisschen
durch wagen verdeckt aber erstens
möchten sie sehen wie der öffentliche
ausgang aussieht wie früher wird das
hier auf einer staffelei ausgestellt
wenn es eine große verkündigung zu geben
gibt und da wird eben der tod von prinz
philip in buckingham palace hinter dem
zaun angekündigt und dafür stehen die
leute momentan an auch um blumen
abzulegen
es kommen doch schon einige dafür dass
die nachricht nicht mal eine stunde alt
ist und natürlich ist die die trauer
groß denn prinz philip über jahrzehnte
hier
der mann der queen ein charaktervoller
mensch ein besonderer prinzgemahl und
die trauer in großbritannien ist groß
ist groß es ist ja auch eine schwere
zeit in der viele menschen tatsächlich
zum königshaus geblickt haben als einem
an einer säule der beständigkeit in
besonders schwierigen zeiten ist der tod
von prinz philip denn jetzt sehr
überraschend gewesen 99 jahre wir wissen
dass er dieses hohe alter hatte er hat
oft viele witze darüber gemacht und
sagte einmal nichts baut einen mehr auf
als wenn man daran erinnert wird dass
die jahre immer schneller vergehen und
dass der lack beginnt vom alten rahmen
ab zu blättern so hat er sein alter mit
humor genommen hatte trotzdem immer so
diesen rüstigen eindruck von sich
gegeben nun war aber nun wochenlang im
krankenhaus ist insofern der tod nicht
ganz überraschend naja bei einem fast
hundertjährigen ist der tod natürlich
nicht überraschend und er hatte eben in
den letzten jahren doch deutlich
abgebaut deswegen hat er sich ja auch
selber in rente geschickt
vor 23 jahren er wollte nicht mehr
öffentlich gemeinsam mit der queen
auftreten weil er sorge hatte dass er
die würde des amtes nicht mehr richtig
repräsentieren kann
tatsächlich war er trotzdem immer noch
sehr lange sehr rüstig es gibt immer
noch bilder vom letzten oder vorletzten
jahr wie er selbst eigenhändig eine
pferdekutsche über stock und stein lenkt
er war sehr lange sehr aktiv darüber
darauf war er auch immer sehr stolz aber
natürlich in den in den letzten wochen
also im februar wurde er eben
eingeliefert mit einer blasenentzündung
ins krankenhaus war vier wochen
insgesamt in zwei verschiedenen
krankenhäusern dann die herzoperation
aber die stimmung war doch eigentlich
hoffnungsvoller entlassen wurde
denn er lief auf recht aus dem
krankenhaus heraus und nach winter
hinein wo er nun heute morgen verstorben
ist ich greife einfach mal auf was du
gerade gesagt hast aufrecht das ist
vielleicht tatsächlich so ein attribut
was man ihm als respekt zollen muss denn
zeit seines lebens war er oder die
bekannte rolle von ihm war eben die
nummer zwei an der seite der queen und
diese rolle hat er doch glaube ich sehr
aufrecht ausgefüllt wir wollen einfach
mal blicken auf diese 9 und 9
sich jahre ein bewegtes leben von prinz
philip prinz philip herzog von edinburgh
pflichtbewusste und unermüdlicher
repräsentant der krone
die einwahl schlichter ehemann der
königin für andere der vielleicht meist
unterschätzte mann großbritanniens
am 10 juni 1921 wurde philipp aktion des
prinzen andreas von griechenland und
prinzessin elisa von battenberg auf
korfu geboren wenn ich später musste die
familie ins exil fliehen die ehe seiner
eltern zerbrach philipp wurde zu seinem
onkel lord mountbatten nach england
geschickt
rasch machte er karriere in der
britischen marine
[Musik]
bereits mit 13 jahren so heißt es soll
sich die junge elisabeth unsterblich in
den sparten offizier verliebt haben ihre
verlobung folgte 1947 die vielumjubelte
hochzeit philip heiratete die damals
vielleicht begehrteste junge frau der
welt
nach elizabeths krönung nur fünf jahre
später waren die rollen schnell verteilt
die queen hatte england verlebt die
familie
er traf die entscheidungen bei der
erziehung der kinder seine laufbahn in
der marine musste der prinz auf geben
dennoch gelang es ihm als schirmherr von
mehreren hundert wohltätigen
organisationen weiter ein eigenleben zu
führen
am bekanntesten seiner rolle als
präsident des world wildlife fans wohl
schon früher als mahner ökologischen
bewusstseins auf sich aufmerksam machte
ich sehe nicht wie wir weiter
wirtschaftliches wachstum haben können
ohne stärker auf die umwelt zu achten
[Musik]
andererseits war der prinz auch äußerst
technikbegeistert zu ließ er es sich
nicht nehmen die berühmte concorde
einmal selbst auszuprobieren was dann
allerdings zu der frage führt die er die
große lärm und abgas belästigung mit
seinem umweltengagement vereinbaren
können nun ich habe drin gesessen und
ich habe nicht gebaut
schlagfertig war ja der prinz manchmal
aber auch nicht ganz pannensicher wie
zum beispiel 1997 auf der hannover messe
als er den bundeskanzler versehentlich
als reichskanzler anredete begierig
lauerte die presse auf ausrutscher des
prinzen opfer sprecher oder auch manch
bewusste provokation philipp war immer
für eine schlagzeile gut
2017 im alter von 96 jahren trat er in
den ruhestand zog sich von seinen
öffentlichen verpflichtungen zu rücken
die kuba-krise überstand er gut
geschützt gemeinsam mit der königin auf
schloss windsor
man sah ihn nur noch selten wie bei
diesem rücktritt von einem seiner
letzten militärischen ämter aber ein
mann mit haltung ein mann mit ganz
eigenem charakter und so wird prinz
philip den briten in erinnerung bleiben
[Musik]
ja diana 99 jahre ein bewegtes leben wer
ist dieser mann der ist prinz philip
gewesen nur die nummer zwei im schatten
der ehefrau der queen oder hat er diese
besondere rolle des prinzgemahl doch auf
eine sehr eigene art ausgefüllt also
sehr eigen war auf jeden fall aber ich
würde schon sagen überdeutlich die
nummer zwei die queen überstrahlt doch
alles das ist klar ihrer rolle aber auch
klar ihre persönlichkeit er selbst war
ein eher scheuer mensch er mochte das
überhaupt nicht besonders im rampenlicht
zu stehen und dafür hat er natürlich
eigentlich den falschen job muss man
ganz klar sagen er hat sich seine rollen
gesucht er hat immer ein bisschen
darüber gespottet dass er eigentlich gar
keine richtige rolle hat sondern so eine
art überflüssiges anhängsel ist aber er
war natürlich bedeutsam für die queen
für ihre stabilität und auch für für
ihre jobs sie haben gemeinsam
zigtausende von terminen gemacht und er
alleine hat auch sehr viele termine
gemacht er hat sich selbst als den
weltbesten plaketten enthüller zum
beispiel bezeichnet weil er ständig an
irgendwelchen bahnhöfen krankenhäusern
oder sonstwo einweihungs plaketten
enthüllte das hat er als seine aufgabe
betrachte durchs land zu reisen und
natürlich die königsfamilie dabei zu
repräsentieren die queen selbst hat
einmal gesagt ich muss gesehen werden
damit man an mich glaubt und auch das
hat prinz philip tatsächlich mitgenommen
und diese rolle ausgefüllt auch wenn sie
ihm persönlich eigentlich nicht
besonders lang er hat ja mal in früheren
jahren sich so ein bisschen über diese
nebenrolle beschwert kann man sagen dass
er in späteren jahren sich dann damit
abgefunden hat und ist eben einfach mit
humor den du gerade so ein bisschen
beschrieben hast dann genommen hat mit
sarkastischen
ja ich glaube es war für ihn einfach
wirklich sehr schwer er war ja in der
marine und der war sehr erfolgreich hat
im zweiten weltkrieg tatsächlich auch
noch gekämpft und alle die über ihm
gesprochen haben haben immer gesagt er
hätte mit sicherheit eine großartige
karriere in der marie eine große
leidenschaft und die musste er aufgeben
als elisabeth queen wurde und er eben
dann nur noch prinzgemahl sein durfte
daran hat er lange herum geknipst und
das waren glaube ich schwere jahre für
ihn mit zunehmendem alter hat er dann
natürlich das wahrscheinlich verbunden
und verarbeitet und zwar im auch klar
dann als er älter wurde dass er diese
rolle ja dann sowieso nicht mehr gehabt
hätte er hat sich sehr stark um die
familie gekümmert er war ein präsenter
vater eben auch deswegen weil die queen
nicht sehr viel zu hause war und
insofern war er im grunde genommen ein
sehr sehr berühmte hausmann der der sich
tatsächlich darum gekümmert hat die
familie zusammenzuhalten
jetzt ist es in dem rückblick von deinem
kollegen ja dann ist es ja schon
angeklungen er hat deutsche vorfahren
sehr viel deutsches blut er ist geboren
wurden 1921 als kind von prinz andreas
von griechenland und dänemark und
prinzessin alice von battenberg auf der
griechischen insel korfu und ist ein
spross des hauses ist jetzt muss man
sich festhalten schleswig holstein
sonderburg glücksburg was im grunde
genommen heisst dass es in seinem
stammbaum von deutschen vor deutschen
also nur gewimmelt hat war das denn als
nun dieser vielleicht ja smarte schicke
offizier aber doch mit sehr viel
deutschem blut und vorfahren die
künftige oder dann spätere queen
geheiratet hat ist das so ein bisschen
auch ein nachteil gewesen diese
deutschen wurzeln in seinem leben in
großbritannien auf jeden fall nicht nur
das er dass er deutsch war tatsächlich
er sprach auch bis zum schluss sehr sehr
gut deutsch seine schwestern waren alle
mit relativ hochrangige nazis
verheiratet das hat den dritten
logischerweise auch nicht besonders gut
gefallen als er 1947 zwei jahren nur
nach dem krieg die queen heirat
seine schwiegermutter queen mum hat ihn
immer nur den verarmten hunden genannt
da sieht man auch sie waren nicht
besonders beeindruckt davon welchen
reichtum er mit in die familie brachte
den gab es nämlich eigentlich nicht aber
das nützte alles nichts denn in dieser
partie schon mit 13 jahren seien ob ihr
auge auf ihn geworfen und war nicht
davon abzubringen
philipp zu heiraten es ist eines der
wenigen male gewesen dass die krähen
sich tatsächlich aufgelehnt hat und dem
wunsch ihrer familie sich vielleicht
doch jemand anders zu suchen
widerstanden hat sie war ganz
entschieden und hat damit er muss man
sagen auch auf das richtige pferd oder
in den richtigen mann gesetzt
wir haben es ja eben erfahren dass die
familie von ihm ins exil gegangen ist
und von dort hat er dann die briefe an
die fünf jahre jüngere elisabeth
geschrieben also du sagst ist ja gerade
da war tatsächlich wirklich liebe im
spiel und haben die zwei
zusammengefunden und elisabeth hatte
eben jetzt nicht den allermeisten
geheiratet und ihren eigenen kopf da
durchgesetzt aber dann sind wir bei dem
thema familie war ja eben auch queen
elizabeth ansonsten sozusagen die rolle
ich diene erst meinem land und familie
und eigene interessen stehen hinten an
jetzt blicken wir auf diese familie und
im stück damals eben ja auch gesehen
die rolle der erziehung die familie das
ist alles prinz philipp zu gefallen vier
kinder charles ein
dann andrew und edward vier kinder kann
man denn sagen hat diese erziehung
erfolgreich funktioniert war prinz
philip ein guter familienvater ein guter
erzieher ja da gehen die meinungen
natürlich darüber auseinander hatte
immer ein schwieriges verhältnis zu
charts so viel ist bekannt ein sehr
gutes zu m
wenn man sich die familie anschaut und
die vielen probleme die in den letzten
jahrzehnten mit den kindern der queen
und prinz philips aufgetreten sind dann
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
erfolgreich das war allein die tatsache
dass prinz andrew im grunde genommen
vorgeworfen wird mit einer
minderjährigen sex gehabt zu haben sind
alles so geschichten wo man natürlich
irgendwie sich schon fragt wie
erfolgreich die
dass diese familienbande dabei waren die
kinder in schach zu halten
es ist aber natürlich auch eine sehr
schwierige rolle für alle in der
königlichen familie mit dieser
merkwürdigen position die man ja ein
nimmt einerseits hoch verehrt zu sein
und andererseits sehr kritisch beäugt zu
werden und von philips selbst zum
beispiel ist jemand der den medien
gegenüber immer sehr sehr kritisch
gegenüberstand und diese antipathie ganz
klar auch auf seine enkel weitergegeben
hat vor allen dingen auf harry der ja
bis heute eine art fehde mit den mit den
britischen medien und dem britischen
boulevard fährt ja da muss man drauf zu
sprechen kommen diana da hat es ja am
ende schwerste rassismus vorwürfe
gegeben von harry und megan gegenüber
dem palast dann fragt man sich doch sehr
wer ist denn damit gemeinde am ende sind
so ein bisschen die queen und prinz
philip aus der schusslinie genommen
worden aber hat ihm das auch schwer
getroffen
das wissen wir nicht wie in das
getroffen hat er war ja zu dem zeitpunkt
tatsächlich gerade im krankenhaus ich
nehme an dass er das mitbekommen hat
aber wir wissen nichts darüber was er
dazu gesagt hat ich nehme an die ganze
geschichte hat ihn schwer getroffen
zumal er mit william uns mit harry
einfach eine sehr enge beziehung hatte
wahrscheinlich länger als mit seinen
eigenen kindern
das hat ihn mit sicherheit schwer
mitgenommen zumal es die gesamte
königsfamilie natürlich beschädigt hat
und noch lange belasten wird wir wollen
gleich wir beide noch über prinz philip
weiter sprechen da gibt es noch viele
fragen
allerdings wollen wir einfach mal
reinhören ich habe es eingehend schon
gesagt die bbc spielte sofort nach
bekanntgabe des todes die nationalhymne
und der britische premier boris johnson
hat eine ansprache gehalten da wollen
wir ihn auszüge einfach mal reinhören
nations soweit der premierminister boris
johnson der also erklärt er habe mit
großer trauer
die nachricht von buckingham palace
erhalten mit der information dass eben
seine majestät der duke of edinburgh
prinz philip gestorben sei tolle im
größten respekt das ganze land
großbritannien solle prinz viele größten
respekt und auch alle länder des
commonwealth
in dieser stunde nun gelte oder die
trauer des landes und auch von ihm boris
johnson der queen der gesamten
britischen royalen königlichen familie
die einen hoch respektierten menschen
vater und großvater verloren haben so
weit der britische premier der seine
trauer zum ausdruck bringt diana das ist
sind wichtige worte respekt steckt da
drin eine bedeutende figur ein
bedeutender mensch sagt boris johnson
und trifft damit glaube ich die meinung
von vielen in großbritannien du hast
auch im moment eben erklärt warum wir
haben gesehen soziales engagement auf
der einen standhaftigkeit in der
ausfüllung der rolle
ja aber wir haben eben beitrag eben auch
in der zusammenfassung ein bisschen
gehört es hat auch fehler gegeben es hat
auch rhetorische fehltritte gegeben
andere fettnäpfchen in die prinz philip
getreten ist ist das so ein bisschen ja
zwei medaillen einer person
ganz und gar der war tatsächlich ein
charakter passte sich nicht gerne an und
das muss natürlich ständig tun in der
königsfamilie wir wissen ja wie strengen
das protokoll ist und wie wenig da es
geduldet wird wenn man ausschert aber er
hat sich doch so einige
eigenständigkeiten nicht nehmen lassen
und die waren vor allen dingen verbaler
natur
bemerkungen die man ganz klar als
rassistisch bezeichnen würde
wobei eben wie yasin es sehr schön
formulierte sehr viel gezielte
provokation mit sicherheit auch dabei
war er machte das gerne provozierte
gerne und erfand wahrscheinlich dass die
anpassung die von ihm erwartet wurde
ausreichend war dann musste man hin und
wieder mit kleinen provokationen von
seiner seite rechnen
also man kann sagen charme humor aber
auch ordentlicher bis diana
man fragt sich natürlich automatisch wie
wird das ganze jetzt ablaufen eine
staatstrauer ein staatsbegräbnis gibt es
irgendwelche vorstellungen das
königreich die königliche familie ist
ein unbekannt dafür dass alles minutiös
geplant wird gibt es sozusagen in der
schublade irgendwelche pläne wie ein
begräbnis für prinz philip jetzt
aussehen könnte also er selbst wollte
kein staatsbegräbnis er heute ein ganz
bescheidenes begräbnisses hat er immer
gesagt es obliegt nun allerdings der
queen zu entscheiden wie das begräbnis
aussieht sie könnte es tatsächlich
selbst zu einem staatsbegräbnis erklären
das halte ich für extrem
unwahrscheinlich schon deswegen weil am
kit ist und natürlich die möglichkeiten
für andere staatsoberhäupter oder royale
familien hier anzureisen sehr begrenzt
sind es wird mit sicherheit ein kleines
ereignis werden ist er wird in der st
fazit wenn in münster aufgebahrt und
normalerweise zu normalen zeiten sagt
man wird acht tage lang getrauert und
dann findet die beerdigung statt wir
haben aber momentan noch kein datum für
die beerdigung
der plan ist natürlich nicht draußen
ausgehängt hinter dir vor buckingham
palace sondern wahrscheinlich eben ein
porträt von prinz philip diana vielen
vielen dank du wirst auf jeden fall im
zdf natürlich uns auch weiterhin
informieren darüber wie großbritannien
trauert was die weiteren schritte sind
wie ein begräbnis aussehen wird vielen
vielen dank für die einschätzung für ja
ein bisschen das charakterisieren eines
mannes der 99 jahre gelebt hat ein hohes
alter mit vielen kapiteln und mit vielen
jahr licht und schattenseiten aber auf
jeden fall ein mann der so hat es der
britische premier gesagt viel respekt
verdient von großbritannien den briten
und von round the world der ganzen welt
die ja nach vielen vielen dank für die
einschätzungen und informationen und ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen ganz herzlich für
ihr interesse
das war unser zdf heute live stream zum
tod von prinz philip dem ehemann der
britischen queen elizabeth auf
wiedersehen